Hi. Whole bunch of research to do
today. Whole bunch of research to do
today. Get reream up. Let me get the
graph from uh last night's experiments
up and I will talk about what I'm going
to do today.
quick outline of the
schedule and then we will uh we'll start
on the first block of
stuff. So, first
thing, not a terrible result from last
night. Uh let's
see. So, this is it looks a little
weird. The curve on this was a little
weird. This is neural MMO. This is
30 billion
steps. Yeah, 30 billion 20. Was it says
22 billion? Ah, right. 22 23 billion
steps. Got this curve. We've got this
curve. Yep. We got this
curve. Where is
the Where's the good baseline run is my
question.
Not this
one. We just have to find the uh the
actual good
baseline. Uh yeah, that'll do. This
one's pretty good. So,
uh this is from before we fixed the bug
right
here. And this was a slightly different
one from as well before we fixed bug.
And now we have this one. So, it's a
little less smooth than this one here,
but this still looks like it has
potential to do better longer term. And
this is a pretty early version of the
new code as well. So, I think this is
not bad. Um,
yeah. So, at the very least, we fixed
the bug that was like absolutely
breaking everything. So, here's the plan
for today. I have a few different topics
that need some work.
Um there is an experience buffer. We
came up with a pretty decent
optimization to the experience buffer to
implement.
Um, I want to look
at on policy verse off
policy methods from a number of angles
that aren't typically looked at because
I want to really get a sense of why you
need longer trajectory segments for on
policy learning and if that is actually
true. That's a major thing. Uh, there
were a few other things as well I was
thinking of today. Oh yeah, there's the
diversity is all you need stuff,
exploration algorithm. We have some
experiments to run
there. And
uh if we get through all of that,
there's also some binding stuff where we
can work on making it way easier to
interact with and write various types of
sims with Puffer because there's some
curriculum learning work uh that we've
been looking into on that. So that's
roughly what I have planned for today.
I think
that, you know, I feel pretty fresh at
the moment. We can start with like the
heavier research stuff. Schedulewise,
it's probably going to be I work on this
for about two hoursish. I get breakfast
real quick. Uh I come back, I work on
that for another six hours or whatever.
Four, four to six hours. Quick dinner
break. Come back another couple hours.
And you know, we'll see. Hopefully we're
live at least 10 total hours today. That
is the
goal. At least a good 10 hour workday
for a Saturday. It's that's like
baseline
solid.
Okay. So, first thing I want to
I want to see if these have like times
kind of shot.
Welcome. Let's go to make it review
mode. There we go. I could actually get
like a decent stream over at some
point. I do plan on actually, you know,
building out the stream stuff and taking
that a little bit more
seriously. This is kind of a cool thing.
All right.
So, this is the plot from D from Rainbow
originally. They have one for Atari in
here.
Morning. The PO paper did include full
Atari results, right?
49. This is 40 million game
frames. So the original uh Atari or the
original PO paper only
has 10 million time steps, 40 million
frames. So this is a tiny tiny result.
So, this is going to be apples and
oranges here. Unless they give
us I remember sometimes they uh the deep
mind folks give
you
Actually, this is kind of funny. So,
rainbow on breakout doesn't do as well
as distributional DQM. This is like 400
score or something after 200
mil
frames. What did they get here?
I want to get like a direct comparison
of Rainbow to
um PO uh scorewise but also like
computewise. That's the first thing I
want to do
today. Okay. Yeah. So here they get this
is only 10 million train frames and
they're at 400 here.
Right now that's Acer. What's PO get?
300 that matches cleaner roughly. Well,
cleaner matches this
rather like 300
uh which is pretty darn close to this
thing actually. 10 million frames would
be like over
I want to see how many uh how many times
they use each sample. It's something
ridiculous.
7 million frames in 10 hours wall clock.
That's got to be really slow,
The value of n in multi-step learning is
a sensitive
hyperparameter. So n= 5 does worse than
n= 3. So literally they take into
account three step three-step trajectory
segments. It does worse if you go any
longer.
Let's see what I want to learn or uh
what I want to know here rather
is how many times on average they're
using each sample.
one. Clean RL just
added Rainbow 4 days
atoms.
Okay. So, how does this thing
work? Global step. So, this is epoch, I
assume. And then they should step the M
somewhere in here, right?
M's
reset. They get
actions and then they step the
frequency four. So every
four s every four samples they
train
nums. This is going to be like eight.
It's
one. Literally one. One
environment.
Okay. So, every four
actions. Yeah. Single environment only.
It's This is insane. Uh, this thing I my
guess out of the box just based on that
is this thing is
probably I'm going to say like 200 steps
per
second. So that's
like the puffer implementation for PO is
at least 20,000 on the same Atari
environments. And if you use if you use
our version of breakout on enduro then
you get like two million.
So RL research was really something back
in the day
like see the trick here right is all
these papers they report frames as the
x-axis and they say well if we just keep
the same number of frames but we get
better score that's better and they'll
use like a 100 times the amount of
compute. So yeah, there was a lot of
weird like academic posturing like
saying, "Oh yeah, we controlled for the
same variable, but they control for
variables that just do not
matter." It's really dumb. But basically
what I'm trying to figure out right now
is uh how much more compute Rainbow used
versus PO because I want to get a sense
of whether this algorithm actually does
anything.
Like are there good off policy
algorithms in general or is this just
like people controlling for the wrong
variable and all these algorithms
actually
suck. So this is four steps.
And every four
steps sample args.batch
terrible. That's
eight. So that's on average eight uses
per sample. It's prioritized experience
replay. So it's not actually going to be
like an even eight, but average of eight
reuses per
sample. So that should
be about twice as
much twice as many steps I believe as PO
does. But you also get prioritized
experience with this thing.
Are there actually like good baseline
curves on rainbow anywhere?
on. Oh, come on, guys. They got PO and
DQN.
here? Not a single real off policy
algorithm was
used. Also, they're doing something
really weird if they're seeing DQN doing
better than
They're doing something really
weird. Oh, dang. I was looking at this.
This got Why did this get rejected?
Huh. Now stuff is getting rejected for
being on
I'm very glad to no longer be
publishing.
What is your favorite thinking princip
or
philosophy?
Wait, princcepts or philosophy?
programming.
Are you asking me what my favorite
content is, philosophy content, or you
asking me something
different? Okay, so this is 12 hours is
what he
got on this. Let me see what my
implementation would
get. So that's the baseline.
So 200 million
hours. Okay. So this does 4,000 steps
per second.
So, four to five times slower than
puffer. Um, but we can't say without
access to the implementation whether
they're using four to five times more
samples or if it's just a slower
implementation.
We should see
that. They have this on modern games as
well.
Yeah, that's ridiculous that they get
that this gets
rejected. There's really no point in
being in academia in
RL. Can we figure
out how many steps
You know, it's weird that they still
don't solve Breakout,
right? I guess I'm comparing, though.
It's not entirely fair. Our version of
Breakout's a little different than the
Atari one.
I think this is still better than uh
rainbow,
Wait. Uh that's weird. Alien break.
This is
Wait, isn't that misreported or did I
misread
baseline. It should be up here at
least higher,
right? Yeah, that's like close to 400.
Okay, let's just check Pong or Pong
should be 20 in both, right?
Okay, palm shows 20 in both. Uh, let me
pick one other
as also too.
Okay, so there's some weird misreporting
in
here, but I think that they have the
overall as well, right? So, this
was 200 mil frames IQM
This is mean human normalized
performance. Wait, wasn't the original
higher than
that? No, just over
two. Yeah, that looks like it's just
over two.
Okay, so there's some small
inconsistencies, but um I think the mean
result is about the same.
actually. Can we find
out how many steps they trained though
each
sample? That's what we need right
now. Frame stacked. Yeah. Yeah, that's
normal.
LSTMs. Training for 200 million frames
we will fill into training to 50 mil
steps. Okay, good. So, they did this
correctly
then. Yep. So, this guy actually does
some responsible research. Cool to
M. What are your thoughts on
TDMPC2RL
algorithm? Never heard of it.
What is
this? Uh, this is world
[Music]
against? Control my
suites. Mostly robotic stuff, which is
why I probably haven't seen this.
something. So, we do have a published
paper on uh studying some of the stuff
in Dreamer V3 and it did not hold up at
all. But I think that they are
not Hold
on. This is steps. Do they have wall
clock?
They have model
parameters. Oh, this is
massive. They're training ridiculously
sized models for the task of this.
That's
So, what did I say like uh 20 minutes
ago about people just messing with the
x- axis a
bunch? I'm pretty sure the dreamer ones
was like a day and that was already a
lot. Yeah. I don't know. I want to do
some stuff in world modeling, but just
like papers like this really don't do
anything for me because they're
controlled for completely the wrong
variable. And so you can't really
compare them to
anything. Like literally nobody cares
about this variable at all outside of
academia. And everybody controls for
this. Like nobody cares about steps. The
only time you care about steps is if you
have a slow simulator and then you still
don't use it as the x-axis. You still
end up with ball clock time and you're
just constrained to the speed of that
simulator. Hang on. This is a 64 batch
size gradient step.
step you take a batch
size of
How does that make
sense? They do multiple batches or
something. Gradient updates to
environment
steps. Taking one step in 64
environments with one gradient update.
How does that give you one over 64? Am I
done?
One step in 64
environments and one gradient step with
a batch size of 256.
parallel and performing updates on
larger batches can significantly reduce
wall clock.
Obviously, one
step in 64 environments with one
gradient update with a batch size of
256.
This results in a replay ratio ratio of
ready objects environment 1 over
64 that doesn't follow
right it's 1:4
Four. This is actually then the sample
if I'm reading this correctly. This is
the sample we use. The same sample we
use as PO
defaults. The only difference being that
it's prioritized.
And he got this working on
like some pretty real tasks here.
ations, man. And it's like nobody ever
benchmarks
versus like on policy only benchmarks
versus on policy. Off policy only
benchmarks versus off
policy. You don't need to benchmark
model base versus model free, but on
versus off would be
nice. They've got this massive range,
but it's clearly way out here.
Okay, this is a parameter difference.
up some even decent graphs on this
thing here. It is
right. So, max
pooling
whatever I assume without impala they
mean the architecture.
What is this
thing? Oh, they also have vor
neurons. Let me see this this one thing
that they added here.
thing. Let's go back to the
ablations. That wasn't all the different
things that they threw on it yet.
The fact that they're listing Impala
though is the biggest
thing. Presumably they mean the
architecture. I have to see what that
is.
Yeah. So this is the impala like
architecture. This sort of con block
structure. So whatever this thing is I
have to look at the math and then I
impala are the two big ones.
My guess would be the Impala CNN. Yeah,
I would assume so, right? Because like
Impala was more than just the CNN, like
the architecture like the main actual
thing from Impala
uh was that it was this asynchronous
like infrastructure setup, right? And
then I think they threw a B trace on
stuff to correct for that. But then they
also happened to throw in this like way
better architecture. And then everyone
says that, oh yeah, we use impala, but
they just literally mean like the model
deaf and not all the rest of it,
well. Okay, here
are here are the ablations,
right? oftentimes DQN people use the
impolicy and enter the nature. Yeah. And
it makes it really tough to compare. So
basically what I'm trying to figure out
now is apples to apples. How well does
off policy do versus on policy? Um I'm
trying to see if you can actually find
that if you can find specifically what
things in off policy are responsible for
working at all. And then the other thing
is that like these off policy methods
seem that they only bootstrap over like
three steps or whatever. That's their
effective horizon is three steps and on
policy doesn't work unless you give it
like at least 32. So, I'm trying to
figure out what the heck happened there
because we have this like prioritized
experience replay buffer now in uh in PO
as an option. And uh it works if you
just use it over data from the current
EPOP, but if you try to use stale data,
then you mess up the value function. And
uh yeah, I'm basically I'm trying to
figure out if we can steal some stuff
from off policy without all the baggage
that comes with it. Joined a bit late.
Thanks. Welcome. I will be live here for
probably 10 hours today minus meal
breaks. Welcome to Puffer AI deep
research. Except instead of just typing
stuff in a language model is me sitting
here and reading papers and writing code
all day.
Wait.
So, okay. This is not performance.
They've got dormant
neurons. Isn't a problem.
They've
got Frank
rank weight
norm. None of these none of these tricks
have any impact on anything other than
uh the smaller models being like higher
constant.
Wait, where
[Music]
is they? They actually did some good
research on this. Hang on.
rejected, man. Reviewers are really
dumb.
What are they looking at here? Policy
churn. What is policy churn?
policyness. Oh yeah. So the other thing
I kind of think I figured out
um the other day.
So if we have any
folks in the chat then maybe uh folks
will have some idea on this. But one of
the really really major tricks in
Rainbow that is now also being used
here is multi-step
learning and they have this
defined right here.
So this is literally just discounted
returns over the next n steps. Um and
this is literally like this the same as
what is used in uh generalized advantage
estimation just discounted returns
bootstrapped returns except they only
bootstrap like three steps and they say
it works worse with five steps. Um and
if you look at their
ablations this matters as much as
anything else in Rainbow. Like if you
just take that out, nothing else, you
crash the
performance. This is no longer valid for
off policy though,
right? Because off policy, right, you're
assuming that you have your Q function
at one
state, which means that you know what uh
what the that you know the value if you
take any action to get to the next
state, right? But if you put three steps
in the middle, then you no longer know
the reward that you're going to get.
Like you no longer know the value of uh
of every possible like intermediate set
of
actions. So like the way that off policy
learning is set up to handle off
policyiness doesn't work anymore with
this. I'm pretty sure which is why I
think that this like they bootstrap
three steps forward because obviously
you need to bootstrap forward like you
need to not be training on singlestep
boot uh
bootstraps but they kind of just break
the math and they just do it
anyways. So I don't think off policy
learning actually works with off policy
data because of this thing. So, I think
this is kind of just as much of a a hack
for off policy as like clipping is for
PO with on
policy. Where' the paper
go? Is this
BTR? Did I lose the
paper? Where did the BDR paper go? All
right.
have they got nerd sniped by dormant
neurons?
layer. Nerd
sniped doesn't help. I hate
layerm. H. It helps a little bit overall
on Atari 5, but Atari 5 is not a great
benchmark. See, it's worse on like this
end. A little bit less
stable. Oh, no sticky actions. Wait,
wait, wait.
This is something that I said that
sticky actions were
dumb. I have an article on this on
X on par with everything pretty much.
Slightly better here. No point using
sticky actions.
does better with life information.
Okay, that's kind of kind of interesting
to
know. Did we miss the rest of the
ablations or do they not happen?
Oh, apparently I'm wrong. Apparently,
layer is slightly better.
Okay, it's only on Atari 5, but it is
for Yeah. every single
task. Was I reading the wrong one? Yeah.
Okay, this is the right.
Okay, that norm
in? Wait, did they say where they put
layer?
I'm going to ask the author where they
put layer
or they don't have it in here, right?
Yeah, they don't have here.
I mean, I guess I'm really only opposed
to layer norm because it's slow. Can't
you fuse it? You could fuse the kernel
with a linear layer, can't you? There
should be some way of doing that.
ablations. Uh, are they in the main
text?
report. Oh, here it is. I'm done. Yeah,
right here. Boom. This is exactly the
graph that you want. Now, they only have
this, it looks like, on Atari 5.
We'll have
to just have that be a
thing. So, no. Impala I assume is the
architecture. That's the biggest one,
right?
No. I don't know how to pronounce this
thing. Uh, that also looks pretty big,
right?
Broken, broken,
broken.
vectorization. So literally those two
things are what matter for this the most
like way more than anything else.
architecture and then
calcium. And then I believe if we looked
at the rainbow
ablations, the things that mattered the
most for these
[Music]
were no uh
multistep prioritized experience
double I don't see distributional in
here endstep TD learning
Don't talk about the distributional
thing, but this thing actually looks
like it
Is this even a common paper? Did this
guy just find this thing? No, this is
like some super random paper this guy
just find that made a huge difference
for
him. That's a Google brand
paper, but didn't really get much
attention. Do they have good results on
this? They
do. And this is actually compared to
rainbow, but they don't get as
impressive results because they don't
put this on
right? Okay, let's actually take a
second to understand what the heck this
is and if this
um what this actually does. So, first
let me read their thing on
uh let me just
open Discord for one second because I
think uh I I know somebody who knows the
author
thing? This is where I attempt to
understand math that I did not actually
study.
Bootstrapping is a core aspect of RL
used to calculate target
values with most algorithms using
reward. Okay, except that it's it's
multistep, right?
Yeah. Optimal policy is not known. The
current policy is used.
Ken looks to leverage an additional
estimate in the bootstrapping
process. The scaled log policy to the
loss
idea? Does not use an arc max of next
state. WQN is obsolete.
is you add some constant
times log of the
actions and then this is the same
estimate, right?
So you subtract
out this term from all the actions and
then you add it
uh to the one that you actually
select. Do we have anything that looks
like this
though? Does this work for um on policy
at all?
Let me think if we have anything
analogous
ST up. This is the update
rule. The update
rule. Is this for like tabular or
something? I don't
understand.
Let's see how they introduce
it. Add the scaled log policy to the
immediate
reward. Wait, our core contribution
stands in a very simple idea. Adding the
scaled log policy to the immediate
reward.
It's competitive with distributional
methods on Atari games without making
use of distributional RL andstep returns
or prioritized
replay. So they use this with IQN to
outperform Rainbow.
I'm kind of down to jam some math
today. I'm sure I will bore everyone.
Yep, there goes the viewer
count. But,
uh, I'm down to jam a little bit of
math. Does they do they have any
reasoning for why this is a good idea
anywhere?
Wait, we do we do need to read this.
Okay. Um, most RL algorithms make use of
temporal difference learning in some
way. This is true of one policy as well
with generalized advantage estimation
incorporating that. It's well known good
trapping mechanism that consists in
replacing the unknown true value of a
transient state by its current estimate
using it as a target for learning.
Agents compute another estimate of
learning that could leverage be led to
bootstrap or out their current
policy reflects the agent's hunch about
which actions should be executed next
and thus which actions are good.
Wait, that's what the value function is
for.
But the value function just tracks the
policy. It doesn't contain information
about the action
distribution.
Okay. Optimized for the immediate reward
augmented by the skilled log policy of
the agent.
When using any
scheme, we insist right away that this
is different from maximizing entropy for
maximum entropy RL that subtracts the
scaled log policy to all reports names
that maximizing both the expected return
and the expected
entropy. A reference to the famous patch
of the
surprising adventures of Baron Musen
where Baron pulls himself out of a swamp
by pulling on his own
hair.
Okay. I was wondering if this was some
guy's name. That's awesome.
I don't think I've heard of any of these
guys. When is this? This is like a
quiet 2020.
This is like some quiet nerves paper
from uh when nerps was super crowded
with RL before the deep mind emerged,
right? So these guys just probably
didn't get any recognition at all for
this. Like 100 sites on this cool thing.
rough. DQN does not compute stochastic
policies which prevents using log
policies. Wait, DQN does not compute
stochastic policies which prevents using
log policies.
I guess it doesn't, right? I guess it
depends how you're looking at it. Can
sample from the Q network, right? Well,
PO does. So, we can really
easily we can do this in PO, right?
Because we compute stocastic policies by
default.
So this
thing overtakes
C-51. We provide strong theoretical
insights about what happens under the
hood.
implicitly performs KL
regularization between consecutive
policies.
Because in PO we do a KL clip but we
don't have a KL loss,
right? What's the default PO
implementation? I'm pretty darn sure
there's
We just clip by KL, right? We don't
actually add a loss term with
KL. Where's our
KL? Where's it
approx? So look in PO you compute this
approx but you only use this to clip the
policy. So you don't actually have any
KL regularization added.
I mean, we could easily just kale
regularize to be
implicitly. Well, there is a isn't there
a form of kale or no? There are two
forms of PO, right? There's the weight
clip and the KL clip. There's never a KL
loss. Doesn't TRPO do that though? I
haven't looked at TRPO in a long
time. We show that because this
regularization is implicit comes with
stronger theoretical
guarantees. Okay.
Uh we're not reading the MDP
background standard RL agent maintains
both a Q function and a policy. We have
a value function, but whatever.
So the only thing I'm not sure about
this, so this is kind of an improvement
to
bootstrapping, which is like onestep
bootstrap, which is what's used in uh
DQM. We have a way better
bootstrap in online RL because we use
whole trajectory segments, right? We use
like 32 64 128 length
segments, but there's also implicit KL
apparently.
Okay. So this is just DQN loss
here.
plus regressing the
target. Yeah. So this is going to be the
same as
right?
Here. So here's your one step, right? So
if you set lambda equals zero in J, you
get this target here. And if you look
here, so this is
reward plus gamma B ST + one,
right? So here's reward plus gamma
What's this? This looks different.
Well, your value function is over all
actions, right? It's over the actions of
the current policy in on policy
learning. Here they have to sum over the
policy evaluated on all actions because
Q function is a value is uh is a Q
function contains the future value
depending on every single action that
you take.
So this is kind of the same thing,
right? We modify regression
target. MRL assumes stochastic policy
while DQN computes deterministic
policies. A way to address this is to
not only maximize the return but also
the entropy of the resulting policy.
that is adopting the viewpoint of max
entropy
RF whatever we throw in entropy bonuses
max entropy is really stupid
um like entropy is just a really dumb
metric I've never I don't understand the
people that say that this is a good idea
like whoopdy do your policy behaves
noisily when there's nothing else to do
that's a really bad exploration method
It's straightforward to extend EQN to
this
setting. We call the resulting agent
soft
EQ. Okay, so this thing here, we don't
need to care about this. I'm pretty
sure nothing more than the most
straightforward discrete actions version
of soft actor
critic and we don't need
this because we
have we already get stochastic policy as
non policy learning standard. The last
step is to add the scaled log policy to
the
really? This is the opposite of max
entropy, isn't
it? Isn't this just telling you to be
confident about your predictions?
What does this thing
like do you like crank up your entropy
bonus and then also do this?
I'm going to have to look up the
distributional RL stuff as well, aren't
I?
And there's a bunch of
theory. Let me get their hypers first.
Maybe we'll just go implement this and
see if it crashes everything.
hypers? And then IQ is the thing that
takes us over the
top part.
does worse on Montazuma. The elevator
action
venture. Everything else is fine. Does
way better on asteroids. I wish we had
asteroids. I'm surprised nobody has done
that by now. It's like a pretty nice
environment to implement for Puffer.
Where's Breakout in
here? Beam
Rider. It's another one that we don't
have
yet. We'll try it on
Breakout. Uh, we need the hyperparameter
they use though, don't
we? They probably just have it inlined
instead of in a table.
on.
It's alpha towel. So it's 0.03. 03 *
0.9,
All right, let's
do I mean this is like a oneline a
oneline change,
Yeah. Where are
logics? It's literally just logics of
actions, right?
use. Would they have picked anything
more difficult to spell?
is size of tensor does not match. So we
get
I for
cake. Uh, what is it? Paul's
Gather stuff.
Gather. Hey, sorry I've been sick for a
while. Really happy to see you continue
live streams on YouTube. I hope you feel
better. There's no
fun. And yeah, I
uh I should just be pretty much doing
nothing but streaming dev for the next
few weeks. I'm really trying to get the
next release of Puffer into a good
spot. And that's mostly just me shoring
up. There's some engineering side stuff,
but I also want to make sure that we've,
you know, done a good job
exploring algorithm modifications within
Two. Looks
good. Keep on. Yes,
indeed. I am currently trying to get
myself back into peak condition
after I mean, pneumonia was at the start
of the year, but I'm still not quite
back to peak yet.
That's still going to take some
This
logs I can do this selected
Isn't this going to give you a negative
number?
Wait, this isn't going to blow up, isn't
it? Yeah, this isn't going to blow up
instantly.
probabilities? They probably to soft
max,
props.
Okay. Um, so this gives you log prop.
Oh, can I not just take log prop of
action?
Then it is log props, right? Just add
log prop of
up. Yeah. So that's flattened. So we
need to change this.
Wait, do these things just have log
problem or is that a
this? Wait, why is
this logit minus
x. This is probably uh screwy
optimization stuff, right?
here. Okay. Log prop
here. So they get get action and
value. Okay. So we can just do it like
this. Categorical.log. log problem
action for now,
right? And then I can ask how we
optimize that
later cuz all this was to optimize that
stuff. This category was kind of slow. I
Yep. Uh
except something's wrong with
action. This one should be different,
shouldn't it?
No. Uh, it could just be log. It could
just be a log
thing. I think that that's
right. All
right. Uh, we can always test this after
a little bit as well.
this over
here. Falling off a bit.
So this should match the
uh previous curve. This is just the
baseline. We're expecting a reasonable
enough
solve. It's 9:49. I should order some
Breakfast soon.
runs. We'll let that finish eval. We'll
run the other one and we'll see.
And let me figure out what I'm going to
get in the meantime.
I don't even know why I'm doing this on
my phone.
Doesn't look like it got quite the uh
the same result there.
Right. Check one last thing and I'll be
good.
entropy? Uh this gives you lower
entropy.
it? Am I misinterpreting or is this
thing just literally telling you to be
confident in your
predictions? Let me just at least try
one last thing. Frank cranking it up.
And then we'll
uh we'll sanity check some stuff as
well. We crank the entropy up a little
bit.
They missed a term. This thing just
missed a term, didn't it?
Does that make any sense to
you? It doesn't make any sense to
same. So now the entropy matches, right?
We match the entropy, but the reward
doesn't do any better.
Does anybody have any idea why this
thing would work?
Doesn't make sense to me that this
should help,
right? I'm just trying to sanity check
stuff. That's kind of all I use Brock
for. It's like, am I just missing
something really obvious or does this
algorithm make no
sense? I mean, I can do 0.01, 01.
Right. What if I do like
this. This is what policy gradient does
though.
can be interpreted as a form of KL
divergence
regularization between the current
policy. Oh, I think that this might be
off policy specific, right?
Or alternatively, you might need to
recomputee this
term, right? You might actually have to
recomputee this bonus in the
um in the training
code. So, it's possible that this is not
like you can't just add it here.
Hang on. So if you were to add this
thing instead of where you get the
rewards the first time, right? If we
were to add this thing when we compute
the
paper. Hang on. I'm not so sure sure
about
that. Doesn't this seem like this is not
just added to the reward, right? This is
added to the update.
I actually think that this is added
to hang on. So if you add this to the
update instead, right?
bonus. Yeah, it just ends up as implicit
kale regularization,
right? I think it just ends up as
implicit kale
regularization. Why do they say this is
better than explicit kale?
right, I'm going to use a restroom real
quick and then we're going to review
this math and see if this algorithm
makes any sense. Just one second.
right, let's see what their math says.
This make any sense?
Yes, this is just an alternate way to do
KL kind about
Okay. Yeah, I'm pretty sure Brock is
growing here. pretty sure that you would
have to you have to apply
this every
update. So it would just be easier to
just do KL
regularization since we already have
that
TRPO. Uh, this paper, everyone hates
this paper because this paper just has a
bajillion lines of math for no apparent
reason, right?
though. Maybe we do end up playing with
KL off of
this.
Okay, we can do that real quick. I've
got a little bit of time is here, I
believe.
only a couple of minutes. All right,
we'll try one thing real quick because I
do I want to try one
thing.
Um, where's the replay factor on
this? Oh, I added this to the totally
wrong branch, didn't I?
benchmark new branch
training. We'll add the replay factor
and then maybe we'll play with KL on
that.
though
actually kale doesn't help
right it's the value function that gets
stale not the
policy so actually any of these like
trust region based things are just bad
for that
Okay. Kind of want to try without
flipping then.
Okay, so here's the new branch, right?
This is what we have here.
This is the old baseline for whatever
reason. Oh, that's interesting. Do we
just fail without
flipping? Is that what's going on here?
We just fail without
flipping. That seems much more
interesting to investigate, right?
It does actually do something. But
that's a huge difference in
Okay, we will investigate that
afterwards. Basically, the goal for all
this stuff is to figure out if um there
any simple things we can steal from off
policy learning that would make uh an
experience buffer more stable for PO
just so we can use like a couple high
value trajectories, high advantage
trajectories. I'm going to go get some
food. I will be back after a quick
breakfast. Uh, and I will be streaming
for a whole bunch of more hours today
after that. So, if you are interested in
following my stuff, you want to help me
out for free, just start the repo. We're
trying to hit 2,000 stars. If you want
to get involved with a dev on any of
this stuff, some of our best
contributors came in with zero RL
experience. Join the Discord. You can
follow me on X for more reinforcement
learning content. We've also got a lot
of fun demos on puffer.ai as well.